EMILY RAPP: Hey, everyone.
Welcome to "Analytics
in a Multi-Cloud World."
I'm Emily Rapp, product
manager at BigQuery.
We are facing a data explosion.
175 zettabytes--
that's 21 zeros--
21 zeros of data in
the world by 2025.
Where's it coming from?
We have cat videos,
server logs, monitoring.
There's retail data.
When you're thinking
about e-commerce,
it's a lot more than just
that final transaction.
It's every point
on the sales cycle.
IoT, manufacturing,
even my washing machine
is connected to the internet,
and therefore generating data.
We have all of this
data at our fingertips.
But we just can't
quite get to it
because we're living in
this world of data silos.
There's organizational
separation.
IT departments are
often centralized.
And they are separate from
the central data department,
if there is one,
which are even then
further separated into
the business units.
And those business
units also have
analysts, data scientists
working and trying
to understand problems.
It's fragmented.
You have data originating from
a bunch of different sources.
It's all in different
formats with various levels
of processing.
This means that our analysts,
our data scientists,
our users--
our users are using
too many tools,
have to get data
from too many places,
and they're making
too many copies.
Why is this happening?
A key component is shown in one
of the Gartner cloud adoption
surveys.
81% of companies who
are using public clouds
are actually using more
than one cloud provider.
And so that means that
multi-cloud management is
becoming-- actually,
it is a true challenge.
IT leaders, they want to
be agile, flexible, secure.
And analysts and
data scientists,
the ones that are actually
doing the day-to-day work
with that data,
they're just trying
to help their organization
make the right decisions.
And even if organizations decide
to have a centralized data
approach, like we talked
about in the earlier slide,
there's still always going
to be separate business
units, subsidiaries, partners.
Multi-cloud is and will be
the world we're working in.
We need to solve for
these macro challenges.
So today, we're
introducing BigQuery Omni,
a flexible, multi-cloud solution
that lets you analyze data
across clouds.
You don't have to
leave BigQuery.
It's your familiar
interface, same experience.
But now, you can
actually reach out--
reach out across those silos.
BigQuery Omni is now in alpha.
And what's really cool is
that it's powered by Anthos.
We don't have to do that
moving and copying of data.
SPEAKER: As a data analyst
in the marketing department,
BigQuery Omni enables me
to use historical sales
data in my upcoming
marketing campaigns.
Using our orders
data, we're going
to validate the
hypothesis that we should
be focusing our marketing
efforts beyond just
food and beverage.
Our first query uses the
HyperLogLog approximation
function to sort the
departments by number of orders.
We are using our read-only
external connection,
Retail Read, to get the data
from the Orders External table.
The query returns
the departments,
sorted by number of orders.
And as we can see, all top 10
are either food or beverage.
This validates our
hypothesis that we
should be focusing our marketing
efforts on this customer
segment, household, or personal
care product purchasers.
Now we need to
build a list of IDs
using our customer data set.
The customer data has
personal information,
including name and zip code.
And we need that data to
stay within the AWS region.
However, we do have a
de-identified user ID field
that we can use
in our campaigns.
Our next query will build
our audience segment,
buyers of household or
personal care products.
Since our campaigns
are regionalized,
we only want customers
from Oregon or Washington.
Now, we have a list of IDs that
can be used in any marketing
activation channel.
We want this data to be
accessible to our marketers,
not just the analysts.
So I use our right connection
to export the query result
to the marketing folder
that they have access to.
And that is how you
can use BigQuery
Omni for data-driven
marketing activation.
EMILY RAPP: That was
pretty cool, wasn't it?
Let's talk about bringing
multi-cloud analytics
to your data.
First, we have to
break down those silos,
get you to getting
insights faster.
Tap into the power of BigQuery.
It's cost efficient,
no moving or copying.
You just instantly
query, instantly
get your results with that
consistent experience.
It doesn't matter if your
data is in Google Cloud, AWS,
or, coming soon, Azure.
You can just use the
same standard SQL,
the same BigQuery
familiar interface,
write queries, build dashboards.
Because the reality is
data, it's not just numbers.
It's not just bytes stored in
some data center somewhere.
It's the way that we can
actually communicate.
We can tell stories.
We can answer questions.
We want you to be able to have
the ability to actually work
across those data silos.
That data that was
at your fingertips,
let's get closer to it.
And we're able to do that
because under the hood,
we use Anthos.
We think about BigQuery.
BigQuery is the separation
of storage and compute.
What does that mean?
It means you can scale up
and say, hey, sometimes when
things are going crazy, you may
need a little bit more compute.
In other cases, maybe now
you're gathering a bunch of data
and so you need storage.
We were thinking about how do we
solve this data silo question?
But the challenge was
we have to figure out
how to get compute to the
data, even if that data is
in another cloud.
So BigQuery Omni, we run
the compute clusters,
known as Dremel, on
Anthos clusters in AWS.
We have a secure
connection, because it's
really critical-- we
think of that single pane,
that the control
plane and the metadata
can remain on Google Cloud,
but only the query result
actually passes through
the BigQuery routers
and then our secure connection
to the next region, AWS
or Azure.
That connection can also
be used when users choose
to bring the results back.
But the key piece is
it's choice for you.
You can bring them back or you
can do everything within AWS.
BigQuery Omni is a
fully managed service.
A question I hear
is, oh, so I have
to use my Anthos or my Compute?
Nope, we got that covered.
We do need your storage.
And it's really critical that
you maintain the access control
to that storage.
But with the compute
resources running locally,
all that's done
behind the scenes.
And you can just
answer those questions.
So how do we actually solve
some of those business scenarios
with BigQuery Omni?
This one's funny.
This is my old world.
Up until recently, in September,
when I joined BigQuery,
I was the infamous marketing
analytics adds measurement.
Specifically, how
many people saw my ad?
It's a surprising hard question.
And actually, it's even harder
to actually think about OK,
now I figured out what's going
on in my marketing campaigns.
What about my audience
behavior in my apps on my site?
What impact did those
two have on my sales?
So let's think about how
could we solve that problem?
How could we see the impact?
We could visualize.
So use BigQuery.
Query Google Analytics 360
ads data in Google Cloud.
And then tap into your
e-commerce data and app data
that's on AWS S3.
Now with Looker, you
can build a dashboard,
so you or those executives
that we all have to worry about
can actually look at what
the audience behavior is
and purchases alongside spend.
It's pretty amazing what seeing
something visually can do.
It's like oh wait,
there's a spike.
And then you also
talk to people.
It's like no, really?
Building a dashboard when
data comes from all of those
different places,
and more importantly,
making sure that if you share
that dashboard with someone,
they're not going to see
something that they shouldn't--
it's surprisingly challenging.
Now let's get a
little bit deeper.
This is something I'm
sure probably many of you
are familiar with, the
OK, my business team
said you need to use
the app data that we
have to do smart things.
And we need that data.
And we need that data here.
And it needs to be formatted
and easy to get to and fast.
So as a data engineer, you
end up running thousands
of daily jobs to process logs
and build cross-cloud ETL
pipelines.
And what happens if
those pipelines go down?
So I've actually seen it where
instead of fixing the pipeline,
companies will
sometimes just hire
consultants to respond
to tickets to answer
the questions.
It's that complicated.
With BigQuery Omni,
it's not always
just about getting new
things with dashboards.
It's looking at your
existing workloads
and how you can optimize them.
You have those petabytes
of click stream
logs that we talked about.
And for some reason,
every app always
ends up going into different
S3 buckets with parquet files.
Today, you have those
thousands of jobs
that we talked about running.
And all you're trying to do is
build audience lists and CSV
files of your active users.
Replace that with a single SQL
query that any analyst can run.
So now that any analyst or
data scientists can just
run a SQL query, let's
think about how that data
scientist can actually use the
data from sales to not just
understand their
existing audience,
but reach new audiences
more effectively.
SPEAKER: Let's get started
with BigQuery Omni.
In the BigQuery UI
on Google Cloud,
choose the public cloud region
where your data is located
and run your query,
the same query
you would use to work with
data that's stored on GCP.
The query is passed to
the other public cloud.
And all of the compute is
done within that public cloud
region.
The results are returned
to the BigQuery UI.
Or you can choose to export
the results directly back
to your data storage on
that public cloud, which
means there is no cross-cloud
movement of results or data.
You can start using
BigQuery Omni right away.
There's no need to do any
formatting or transformation
of your data.
BigQuery Omni supports formats
such as AVRO, CSV, JSON,
ORC, and parquet.
You also don't need to move
or copy your raw data out
of the other public cloud,
do any cluster management,
or provision any resources.
All computation occurs
within BigQuery's
multi-tenant service, which
is running on the region
where the data is
currently located.
Behind the scenes,
BigQuery's query engine
is running on our
Anthos clusters
within the BigQuery
managed service.
We get the data from data
storage within your account
only once you've
authorized permissions
via your other public
clouds' IAM roles.
Those roles are tied to a
BigQuery Omni connection
object.
You can change, grant, or
revoke access at anytime.
And the connection object can
be shared to multiple users
within that same project.
We maintain a secure connection
to bring your query results
back to Google Cloud.
Welcome to BigQuery Omni.
EMILY RAPP: OK, so
we did that query.
We exported it back to AWS.
And now it's time to activate
your cross-cloud data
story, which means think
about that Google Analytics
data that's coming in.
Think about the S3 data storage.
And take those audience
lists and do things
like look-like targeting.
Ever had that experience
where you buy something
and you still see the ad
over and over and over again?
And you're like come on, I
bought that thing already.
Stop wasting your ads on me.
Now, we can actually
solve that, because we
can tie that commerce
data to the ad platform
in a safe and secure way.
So let's recap.
Embrace a flexible
multi-cloud analytics solution
with BigQuery Omni.
We're going to break
down silos, get straight
to the getting insights
part of data analytics.
It's the fun part, anyways.
Having a consistent
experience across clouds--
it doesn't matter where
your data sets are.
You should be able to use
the standard SQL BigQuery
interface, write your queries,
build your dashboards.
It's all about taking that
consistency and familiarity
to accelerate the
time to insights.
You want to be able to
wake up in the morning,
check your phone, be
like, OK, we're good,
and go back to sleep, not
have to worry about writing
a whole ton of different
queries in different tools
before you know the
state of your business.
And all this is possible
because of Anthos.
Dremel was built by Google.
Dremel is what powers BigQuery.
Anthos-- it's that next stage.
Thinking about
that Gartner quote,
81% of companies-- it's
probably, actually, more
than that, I would say, maybe.
Think about everyone has
some part of their business
that's on some other cloud.
And so by bringing
the data to you,
we bring the compute
to where your data is.
We worry about the
infrastructure.
Don't worry about spinning
up clusters, managing them.
We got that.
You focus on driving
the business,
doing some really
cool data science,
making the decisions
you need with data,
not worrying about
how do I set this up
and what pipeline should I
run, and oh, wait, they broke.
Now I have to hire a
whole bunch of people
to just answer tickets.
Let's get started.
Get started with BigQuery Omni.
Let's take it to the next level.
Take your multi-cloud
analytic strategy
that you've built from a
platform and IT perspective
and bring it to your data.
BigQuery Omni is in alpha.
So if you're interested,
please go to the link
and fill out the form.
Let's break down some silos.